One fantasy I've always had
is being a girlfriend with you.
I'm not kidding.
Oh, me too!
I just, I love you so much.
I love you as a person.
I love you for your profession.
Can I girlfriend out with you for a second?
I would love nothing more.
Okay.
(Elizabeth laughing)
(audience applause)
Oh my God.
This is the best day ever.
This is why people love your show
because it feels like you get girlfriend time
with Drew Barrymore.
And I'm gonna get girlfriend time with Elizabeth Moss,
my hero.
Okay, let's do this.
All right.
Now I wanna like know the woman behind the woman
with funny random little facts,
like favorite song right now.
Oh.
Lorde, probably.
The new Lorde album, which I just kind of just...
I know it didn't just come out, I don't think.
But I've just started listening to it.
I don't have a favorite song yet,
but the album I'm really into.
I'm a little late to the game though. I think.
But anyways, I love Lorde.
Lorde, good choice.
Great choice.
My daughter's obsessed with the "Green Light" song,
and I think that's from a-
That's from the previous.
But that's her track right now.
Okay, do you have a favorite cocktail?
Moscow mule.
See, I love this.
In a copper cup.
Oh yeah.
Ah.
Now I know what gifts to do.
What makes you laugh?
Oh, my brother.
My brother, who I think is the funniest person ever.
I love that,
'Cause I have two daughters and all I care about
in this world is them having each other
and being close and fostering that.
Yeah.
So this is important information for me.
Okay, good.
Thank you.
That gives me hope.
Well, what really tick you off?
Ooh, what ticks...
Oh, you know what tick me off.
This is an honest answer.
When people's say oh I didn't wanna bother you with that.
Oh!
That really ticks me off.
Because eventually, as you know, as a producer,
a person who's running anything, you know,
it's gonna be your problem.
Eventually it's coming your way.
But when it comes your way, it's kind of sometimes too late
and it's a bigger problem.
So I feel like there's is a condescension in that
that maybe women experience more than men.
I don't know.
But it really ticks me off.
I'm like, bother me.
It's fine.
I can take it.
Okay, you have two cats, Lucy and Ethel.
Yes.
And is it true you adopted them on a film set?
Yeah.
They were found on the street in Brooklyn actually,
in Park Slope.
(audience cooing)
I know, little angels.
Look at them.
Oh, I love the tabby.
I love orange cats.
I know, they're so sweet.
Yeah, so they were found on the street
and then we used them in this film that I did
called "Listen Up Philip", an indie film,
and I took them home and I thought I'll find them homes.
And nine years later, here we are.
It's true, once you bring 'em in.
No.
So stupid.
I dunno what I was thinking.
Okay.
One part, maybe in history,
from film or television that you've watched,
is there anything you would ever want to play?
Ooh, that's already been done?
Mm-hmm.
Oh my God.
That's hard cause everybody always does such a good job.
I will say one of my favorite movies is "Gravity"
with Sandra Bullock.
And although I would never do as good of a job
as she did in that film, untouchable, she's incredible.
I would love to do something like that.
That was, you know, required such an amount
of technical perfection, such an amount of concentration.
It's almost entirely a solo performance.
Yep.
She uses almost entirely her own imagination.
I think that would be a really interesting challenge
to do something like that.
And anything sci-fi, I love sci-fi.
Really?
Yes.
Okay.
This needs to happen.
Yes.
You could direct it.
I would love to.
Oh my God, are you kidding?
(audience applause)
You can just direct it with like
the world's greatest actress.
(upbeat music)